- Two years ago,
I judged Miss America
and this lovely ladywon.
(light hip hop music)
You know, it's funny,
I was just, as I was turning
the corner looking at this I was
like, "Fuck, man, I really
miss 2011 Vayner a little bit."
We started this company
literally within weeks of my
daughter being born
and literally
the other night I put
her to bed and I saw a picture
of her when she was like three
and I was like fuck.
All that shit like older
people tell me like enjoy it,
this and that.
I was like yeah.
She's just not, like my
daughter's seven going on 16 and
so and that's kind of like
weirdly I just had that same
exact feeling
turning the corner here.
I'm like, "Fuck, man."
Controlling 50 or 60 personal
feelings and like the mission is
really easy and fun compared
to the fucking insanity were
dealing with right now.
We're gonna try stuff.
It's gonna be a great year.
It's gonna be a
great, great year.
Last year was give room so
what I love to do is like go
and then clean up
and then focus.
Last year was go.
And Justin's smilin' 'cause
he saw it at Wine Library, too.
When you go from
30 to 70, like you go.
- [Justin] (inaudible) the
last Wine Library commercial.
- Oh my God!
We made a local commercial.
That's right.
We produced, fucking it killed.
The commercial,
we made a commercial.
I forgot.
(typewriting typing)
(knocking)
- [Man] Hey, we're ready.
- [Announcer] Executives at
Wine Library wine taste over
500 new bottles
of wine each month.
First is the 2002
Sharpshooter Cabernet.
- Great color.
- Let's bring in 400 cases.
- [Announcer] Next is the
2002 Blue Harvest Merlot.
(spits)
- That was bad.
What's next?
- [Announcer] WineLibrary.com,
tasting bad wine
so you don't have to.
(light hip hop music)
- Do you mind if I
take picture with you?
- (sighs) I'd prefer it.
Everything is predicated on
being the bigger woman and man
in every single situation,
always and
then using me as the outpost.
I mean, we can win real big.
I'm willing to do it.
And now I have Claude too,
fuck, I can really do it.
Literally trying to get into a
place where you're the bigger
person in every situation and
then having a place where you
can take the poison out,
'cause you want to get it out.
You got to eat it is how
we built Vayner originally.
For real, that's how I got
the right foundation at first.
Just getting everybody religious
about I will be the bigger
person like I disagree but I'll
be the one that bends right now
but that I'm to go punch Gary
in the face or Kelly or AJ,
now and Claude is much better
than the combination Kelly and
AJ, this is a real thing so
that's another thing
just to think about.
That's exactly what I'm going
to say them to them as well.
It's insane.
There is no separate,
there should be no separate.
I understand physically even how
big this division is leaders,
it makes sense but is going
to be a constant pressure on
everybody from me in a
real way starting very,
very soon to not
let that happen.
And so I'm glad and then I think
we have those
conversations in summer.
You know, one-on-one,
things of that nature,
that allowed some movement
I think in the fourth quarter as
a preview to it and I'm sure
some pockets are good and some
pockets probably exactly
the same and that's okay.
It just won't be able to be
exactly same bad very long.
Thanks guys.
- [Group] Thanks, Gary.
- Have a great day.
Hit me up if you need me.
- [Man 2] Is that you?
- No.
We start with anything I can
personally answer from for
either one of you to help this.
- Hello, how you doing?
I'm a fan.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- [Woman] Oh, wait,
can I get a picture?
Oh my God, I heard you on
the billionaire (mumbles).
Thank you.
- [Gary] That's great.
I mean we've got
unlimited learning capabilities.
Your company is exactly the
kind of people that we can help.
The issue with companies of your
size normally without knowing
the details, you know that
they think of social and digital
media as a secondary thing and
they're allocating dollars to PR
or direct mail or other things
that then usually gets them in
to a place where they're
not putting the money.
I don't care if
you spend a dollar,
a dollar with VaynerMedia if we
can figure out how to take that
dollar and do
something I will do it.
That's not what bothers me.
It bothers me that you're
spending a dollar with us when
you're spending six dollars
elsewhere on things that don't
matter as much in 2017 and
that's the thing on a call like
this or with a board or a CEO
or CMO or head of marketing that
I'm always trying to have
the first conversation around
because every dollar
we don't have is less things
we can do for you.
That's just common
sense and when you're,
and so a lot of people chince,
oh let's test a
little something.
This is a real thing.
This is the communication of
human beings in our society
today so the only thing
I would say to you is look
make the biggest commitment
financially, emotionally,
strategically that you can to
this and if that's a dollar,
Mazel Tov but that's the
way to think about it.
Hey man.
- [Man 3] My phone's dead.
I was get a picture.
Nice meeting you, man. Richard.
- Nice to meet you, Richard.
Real pleasure.
Your phone's dead?
- Yeah, my phone's dead.
I actually just watched your--
- Brandon, let me
call you right back.
- your interview on--
- Breakfast Club?
- Breakfast Club, yeah.
- I'm gonna hook you up, man.
- [Richard] Really
appreciate it.
- [Gary] Of course.
Have a night out.
- Cool.
- [Man 3] Is Derrick Rose
gonna play in the game?
Is he gonna show up?
- To be honest, to be
honest, I'm thrilled.
I mean, I was so upset two weeks
ago when this thing looked like
they were gonna be a three or
four seed which meant they were
going to sign D Rose,
they we're gonna,
like, this needs to blow up.
They need to get rid of
everybody they've got.
One way to do it,
all the way back,
put yourself in a position
to go all the way this way.
Doesn't happen,
all the way back.
The Cubs finally did it 'cause
Theo knows what he's doing.
You fucking go all the way
down, get all the assets.
Now, they could get hurt.
It doesn't mean you're gonna do
it but next year the Jets should
go 0 and 16 and force it in the
best way they can 'cause there's
two to three big time
quarterbacks coming out
and it's the year.
But classic Jets
they'll probably go 8 and 8.
Not get one of the three kids.
To get all the leverage before
the moment and people are like
but you don't have,
it was Vayner,
you don't have anything.
I'm like, "No, no, no, idiot.
"In one year you're going to
come back here and be sad
"'cause I said," and that's
what happens.
- [Jay] Yeah.
- So I believe it.
You have all the
equity, just (grunts).
- [Jay] Yeah, totally.
- [Man 3] Yeah, that'll all
happen I think and
then the brand stuff too.
It's not just body related,
it's also brand related.
So what we can do is...
- In the same way that
I talk to big versions of this,
CAA, Roc Nation, I'm like
look, we're all gonna
compete on everything.
Everybody's gonna compete on
everything 'cause
it's all colliding.
So to me, I think the thing
to have a serious conversation
about is how do we navigate it
so that it's co-winning instead
of inevitable bumping heads.
- [Man 3] Right.
- Like we do brands,
we do sports, you know?
I'm so pumped.
I'm so hungry.
- [Jordan] Good.
Eat up, man.
- Love you.
'Cause I was like, "Fuck, he
put me through so much today."
He put me through so
much shit, why can't I eat?
- [Jay] You've been lifting?
What have you been doing?
- [Gary] This is my
full time health trainer.
- [Jay] I'm Jay.
- [Jordan] Jordan,
nice to meet you.
- Real pleasure.
(crosstalk)
- [Jordan] Nice
to meet you, man.
- [Jay] Are you mic'd up, too?
Is everybody?
- [Gary] No.
(group laughter)
- [Jay] I'm the
only one not mic'd up.
I'm kind of mad at it
that I'm not mic'd up.
- [Jordan] I wish
I had a mic, too.
It was nice to meet you guys.
- Oh, you set up.
Hear it.
I want the bragging.
That text is unusual for you.
What happened?
Something good happened?
- [Jordan] Yeah, yeah.
- You were DM'ing?
- [Jordan] No.
- No?
- [Jordan] I did my own
#60SecondClub
but for my email list.
I did the seven minute win club.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And it went nuts.
I got a ton of people on that.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Jay] (inaudible)
Not even close.
- Look, man, I think that I,
that me and you guys see the
world the same way and
I think that
we've been executing
against that world longer so
we're further along and truth is
nothing would make me happier
than to be a match for what you
guys are up to at a macro level.
And that can take a million
different forms but I'm super
not scared of it.
- [Man 3] Cool.
- You guys want to sit here
for a month next to my team,
you'll learn everything.
I'm crazy.
I'll give away,
I'll give you all my milk,
I'll give you my cow.
I just think it's all execution.
Lindsay, he needs to get
hooked up with Lindsay.
Alright, my man,
good to see you.
Man, you're in shape, huh?
- [Man 3] I try.
- It's sneaky under there.
It's sneaky under there.
- Why you sneaky athletic, bro?
- Hey guys.
- [Man 4] Hi.
- How are you?
Good to see ya.
Really well, how are you?
- [DRock] Wine Wednesday.
- Oh, it's Wine Wednesday.
Hey guys.
(light hip hop music)
- Do you have any--
- Hold on.
Big shout out to Ryan Conlin.
Sorry, I fucked up, I didn't
see that you made that video.
I thought that was the team.
I just tagged you on
the post and I love you.
(group laughter)
I love him.
What do you want?
I love the man.
Love it.
Pumped, I want the t-shirt now.
Get it on the t-shirt,
say I'm ready.
Fucking Garycorn.
(chimes)
I realize I'm a unicorn.
- [Man 5] Get in some time off?
- I did.
Yeah, for two weeks
we went to, five,
six days to
Anguilla with my wife.
- [Maribel] You got it right.
- I got it right this time.
Thank you.
- And the kids?
- And the kids, yeah.
No, the five days we
had just us which is--
- Cool.
- a real cool thing.
- I had to ask myself
some very serious questions.
Why am I doing this?
It's very important to know.
If you want to end up some
where you have to know
where you want to end up.
Then you have to have a compass
of knowing how to navigate so
for me was it an
artist or famous?
I know I wanted to be an artist.
Nothing against fame,
by the way,
it's just which one do you want
as an experience for you life.
I wanted to be an artist.
So everyday I made decisions
based on being an artist,
not being famous or rich.
- And that's that.
- And the other kind of
interesting caveat is I was
offered a million dollar signing
bonus and I turned it down.
- [Gary] I'm glad
we do this, man.
I've been looking forward to it.
If I could do what you did,
I'd be the fuckin',
I'd be real fuckin' famous
because I really
understand distribution.
- [Man 6] Mhmmm.
- It's the ideas
I just gave you.
It's not how
people are thinking.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- People always
take the easy way out.
The easy way out right
now is make something hot,
let's put it on fucking
Soundcloud and Spotify and
hopefully something pops.
- [Saba] Yeah.
- Fuck hopefully.
- Beautiful.
(group laughter)
- Right? Right?
Distribution.
Of course music.
I want people to hear it.
One thing I'm really good at is
knowing what normal Americans
that aren't into music will
like because I'm actually that.
I'm not a good music person.
I'm being serious.
Like, I know that
for fact but, boy,
do I really understand America.
So I know Billy Williams,
like I know,
that's a hit.
I'm always right
about that shit.
So get that fucking song out.
- [Saba] Yeah.
- I know it.
I just know it
'cause I'm that person.
I'm not Boyd who
really knows music.
I'm being serious.
- [Saba] Yeah.
- Do you understand?
Like I don't know
when that artist is that.
I don't understand.
I know hits.
- [Saba] Yeah.
- Saba mother fuckers,
I've been telling you.
I've been telling you, Chicago!
(Saba laughs)
- [Saba] Definitely, yeah, man.
- I wish you well.
- [Saba] Take it easy, man.
- Alright, Boyd.
(light music)
- [Victoria] Are you GaryVee?
- [Gary] I am.
- [Victoria] I watch you,
I follow your Instagram.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Victoria] And the
other day, I was like,
"He's in Hudson Yards."
(Gary laughs)
Can I get a picture of you?
- [Gary] Sure. Of course.
- My husband is gonna freak out.
He's like Victoria
you have to always,
he's like, "You got to follow
him," and I started following
you a couple days ago.
This is awesome.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- [Victoria] You're
my inspiration.
- Thank you so much.
- [Victoria] You
really, really are.
- Thank you so much.
- [Victoria] Husband's kind
of branching out on his own.
- Well, wish him luck.
- [Victoria] And he follows you,
you're a great inspiration.
- [Gary] What's his name?
- Jamal.
- Jamal?
- Yep.
- Alright, what we doing here?
Jamal, what's up, man?
It's GaryVee.
Just want you to know
I'm rooting for you, man.
Get it, get it.
I'm proud of you.
Do it.
So nice to meet your wife
and I hope you win brother.
Talk to you soon.
(hip hop music)
I'm saying that
some people may hear
Miss America and may think
you're a dumb pageant girl.
- [Kira] Yeah, totally.
- And some people may think
you're Miss America and want to
do business with
you because of it.
I'm busy, why did I
say yes to Miss America?
Because when I was little
we first came to America,
my mom and I and my
sister would watch it.
And it felt very, it felt like
a very special part of my life.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Gary] Do you what I mean?
(hip hop music)
I'm like damn.
How'd he judge Miss America?
- [Gary] I was also in a very
different place in my career
even three years ago.
- [Kira] Yeah.
- Four years, what was it?
Three years ago?
Two years ago
I judged Miss America and
this lovely lady won.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
(DRock laughs)
No, thank you.
(loud music)
How are you, my man?
How are you?
- You got to take a shot?
- Done.
My dad's gonna be real happy.
- Take a shot--
- Sasha V's gonna be real happy.
(group laughter)
- Take--
- Oh-
- that full thing.
Thank you.
(rap music)
- [Yung] Play it for me.
- Aw, man, thank you
man, that's tremendous.
- Yeah, man.
- She was telling me
you was coming through.
She's like GaryVee.
I'm like, "Hell yeah!"
(Gary laughs)
- [Tiffany] He
didn't let me finish.
- They said out your whole name,
and I didn't know
your whole name.
- [Gary] Uh-huh.
- When they said
GaryVee, I said,
"Hell yeah, let him through."
Watching your
stuff all the time, man.
- [Gary] I appreciate it,
my man.
- Seriously, man.
- [Gary] Thank you
so much for the love.
That's real good, man.
Like I said, it's so weird that
the hip hop artist that ended up
blowing up for you is
going to end up being me.
(group laughter)
How you doin'?
- [Tiffany] I'm good.
- [Gary] Boys love you.
- [Tiffany] Yeah. (laughs)
- [Gary] They've been
hyping you so much.
I'm like I can't
wait to meet her.
- [Tiffany] We had a good time.
- [Gary] That's good.
- [Man 6] You need
any water or anything?
- [Gary] To me, there's
only three or four pillars of
culture, right?
- [Yung] Right.
- Music, sports and so
I don't know how
well you know Mike.
You guys know each other, Boyd?
- [Mike] We never met before.
- Got it. So, Boyd's incredible.
You'll get to know him.
I put up the money for
Boyd to manage Rome Fortune.
It's so hard to have something
like it happened to you.
It's hard to be LeBron.
It's hard, it's hard to,
even where Dave's
at right now on the cusp.
It's hard.
- [Yung] Yeah.
- And the only thing
these kids are doin',
is either trying to be
Steph or tryin' to be you.
And the reality is
the math is bad.
Meanwhile, I'm
like mother fuckers,
you could $100,000 a year if
you get your shit together and
just focus on this shit.
In addition go try to do that
but do this too and so that's
what I'm really
passionate about.
- [Yung] I just think that it's
dope that you really care about
other people like just
make it a different way,
you know?
- You know what it is?
I'm good enough to get mine.
- [Yung] True that.
- Do you know what I mean?
When you're good, you want
other people to win too because
you don't need to tear
down other people's shit.
You got yours so I've got my
and I want other people to win.
- [Yung] Exactly.
- That's how I think about it.
- [Yung] How you
gonna give back?
- I give back now so the guy
by the name of Scott Harrison,
he did Charity: Water.
He caught me real proper once.
We were having
dinner like this, jammin,
he's like, "I know who you are."
I'm like, "Okay, what you know?"
He said, "You're
gonna make a lot,
"a lot of money and you're a
good dude and when you're 60,
"you'll start giving it away."
- [Yung] I'm not,
I'm not feeling that.
- That's what he said.
- [Yung] You don't, you're
not real until you give back.
- Agreed.
- [Yung] These guys--
- And that's what he said,--
- [Yung] Just like you meet
somebody like you and give them
that same inspiration,
I'm talking personally.
Like I want to see
you give that back.
It could be me, you know?
It could be anybody.
It could be the next person.
- Yep.
- [Yung] Just give them that--
- Yeah.
- inspiration.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- I agree, man.
- And I see how you're moving
I see the people
that you're with--
- Yep.
- You inspire good energy.
- I appreciate that, my man.
I feel the same about you, man.
- [Yung] Let's just turn up.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Next time, let's go to some
hospitals if you
really about that.
- In. In.
- [Yung] Done.
- That's easy.
That's easy, I'll go tomorrow.
I'll change my schedule,
I love that shit.
You only live, (sighs), in.
(piano music)
Take care, stay well.
- [Tiffany] Watch your head.
(Gary laughs)
- Alright, fellas.
- See you tomorrow, boys.
- See ya tomorrow.
I'm out.
- Now that I know a
little bit about your schedule,